et notre invité on va le demander notre
invité politique ce matin c'est Patrick
canaire sénateur du Nord président du
groupe socialiste au Sénat et on va
demander pour vous un verre d'eau
évidemment on va vous l'apporter en
direct on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes avec Julien l'Écuyer de la Voix
du Nord bonjour Julien bonjour Oriane
merci bonjour monsieur canard merci
d'être avec nous Julien on va évidemment
parler de la réforme des retraites
Patrick annère pour commencer d'après
les premiers chiffres la journée de
mobilisation de demain s'annonce forte
journée noire donc du coup pour les
usagers est-ce que vous pensez que le
cap du million manifestants se
rafranchit est-ce que pour vous c'est ça
le cap d'une mobilisation réussie selon
la police ou selon les syndicats
symbolique qui a été lancé notamment par
mon ami Fabien Roussel
vous le reprenez à votre compte
qu'on a pas eu un million de personnes
dans la rue mais ça se mobilise très
fortement moi je je le sens dans les
services publics mais aussi dans les
entreprises il y aura beaucoup de
retraités aussi dans la rue qui
craignent pour leur pouvoir d'achat dont
on parle d'ailleurs rarement au moment
de se débat
voilà il faut qu'il y a un signe qui
soit lancé à Emmanuel Macron parce que
pour moi le fautif de tout ça c'est une
personne c'est Emmanuel Macron
il viendra de la rue il viendra de notre
travail parlementaire le moment venu il
viendra aussi des partis politiques et
on l'a vu hier avec un beau meeting qui
a eu lieu à Paris unitaire
donc tout ça se mobilise la vraie
question est-ce que c'était utile tout
ça est-ce que le finalement notre pays a
besoin d'avoir un tel mouvement social
qui est peut-être va durer dans le temps
alors que nous sortons de la covid alors
que nous sommes en pleine pâte
d'inflation justement monsieur kaner
est-ce que dans ce contexte là vous en
appelez comme certains au sein de la
gauche ou blocage du pays pour lutter
contre cette réforme non c'est des mots
que je ne que je ne pratique pas de le
problème c'est la colère qui est en
train de monter et les gens n'en peuvent
plus écouter hier soir sur une une
grande chaîne de télévision
d'informations qui n'était pas publique
finale désolé j'avais une réunion
tardive et je suis en train de hôtel
parisien à 23 heures et je tombe sur le
patron de Système U monsieur Schelcher
que vous connaissez peut-être donc
ligne de magasin populaire etc
et il était interrogé sur la situation
sociale des Français et là c'est un
élément quand même qui fait de la peine
moi je le dis il me disait le 24 25 du
mois d'habitude les personnes modestes
changent leur caddie d'ailleurs on passe
du poisson de la viande viande hachée
etc
25 24 25 et là il dit mais tous les
chiffres me démontrent puisqu'ils ont
des statistiques bien sûr
algorithmes
15 du mois le 15 du mois donc quand vous
avez des Français qui souffrent en
dehors du problème de la retraite mais
qui se stresse multiplie les inégalités
qui qui augmentent quand ils voient
enfin pas eux mais nous quand vous voyez
le rapport Oxfam qui est sorti à 3-4
jours grande ONG qui dit que 42
milliardaires français ont vu leur
richesse augmenter de 59% 220 milliards
d'euros en trois ans dans ce pays
attention danger
en effet que cet agrégation des colères
pourrait mener à une explosion oui
exactement et
gilets jaunes puissances 10 donc et la
vraie question puisque il y a un terreau
de colère de vraiment de caractère
insupportable des inégalités sociales
est-ce que cette réforme des retraites
n'est pas voilà
l'étincelle l'étincelle qui mettra le
feu à toute cette voilà cette situation
moi je suis inquiet on va on va parler
évidemment du fond de la réforme mais
toujours sur la la manifestation les
mobilisations de demain la CGT énergie
menace d'avoir recours à des coupures
ciblées contre les élus qui soutiennent
le texte est-ce que vous apprenez ces
méthodes
parce que je pense que des élus qui ont
été élus par définition et légitimité il
faut les respecter on les combats là où
il faut les combattre dans les
collectivités au Parlement dans des
meetings mais pas de menace personnelle
c'est comme c'est comme quand on cache
une permanence d'un élu d'un
parlementaire non non je suis pas
favorable à ça il faut pas stigmatiser
il y a des outils il y a la grève il y a
la manifestation il y a la contestation
parlementaire pas d'attaque à domination
le grand débat que réclame le secrétaire
national du PCF Fabien Roussel grand
débat suivi d'un référendum pour vous ce
serait une piste utile je sur un sujet
aussi tranché tranchant clivant face à
un président de la République qui
retrouve ses vieilles habitudes
finalement mais moi je suis enfin si
vous reprenez des vieilles émissions de
publicité là j'ai souvent dit qu'il
voulait avoir raison tout le temps tout
seul contre tout le monde on retrouve
cette logique là donc si le président
pense avoir raison tout le temps tout
seul complètement son programme
présidentiel il applique son programme
et il a pris une réforme qui est votée
depuis quelques années au Sénat par la
majorité de droite
il cherche d'ailleurs à conforter cette
majorité d'ailleurs on le voit depuis le
début du quinquennat quand vous regardez
tous les textes passé c'est souvent LR
qui sert de béquille
mais il est pas vraiment seul là-dessus
il est avec ceux une minorité de
Français qui sont contents de la réforme
quand vous regardez les sondages qui est
content de la réforme déjà beaucoup de
retraités qui sont en place notamment
les retraités aisés bah oui ils sont là
ils sont pas concernés deuxièmement le
patronat dans sa large majorité et les
cadres supérieurs qui a priori n'importe
comment vous avez connu une réforme des
retraites qui emportait la majorité des
Français il y a en tout cas il y a des
réformes qui sont plus ou moins
consensuelles et la réforme Touraine
regardez bien elle est passée
tranquillement parce que elle était vous
savez une réforme de retraite c'est
toujours un sujet compliqué mais l'été
plus juste je dis pas qu'elle était
totalement
pousser les Français à travailler
jusqu'à 64 ans oui mais avec le droit de
pouvoir partir s'il le souhaite à 62 ans
et avec pour les carrières longues
toujours les 60 ans je vous rappelle que
la fin de Touraine avait des critères de
pénibilité sans avoir toutes leurs
années
longs ils peuvent partir mais vous aviez
notamment les critères de pénibilité
huit critères il y en a quatre qui ont
sauté avec les ordonnances Pénicaud au
début du quinquennat précédent
d'Emmanuel Macron et qui permettait
finalement une partie non négligeable de
français de pouvoir partir réellement 62
ans dans la réforme Touraine il parlait
il partait au-delà de de l'âge légal il
était obligé de cotiser 43 ans le
minimum vieillesse qui avait été décidé
en 2003 il n'a pas été mis en place par
la réforme Touareg est-ce que véritable
simplement le gouvernement que auquel
vous avez participé et crédible pour
critiquer aujourd'hui la réforme des
retraites nous sommes crédibles puisque
encore une fois nous avons maintenu à 62
ans l'âge de départ légal là je pivot et
que lors alors que Jean-Luc Mélenchon
allait à l'époque réclamer le retour à
60 ans ce qui n'a pas été voulu par par
François Hollande exactement et
aujourd'hui je pense que le retour à 60
ans peut-être un objectif à moyen long
très long terme mais aujourd'hui n'est
pas raisonnable c'est important de le
dire mais en l'occurrence on ne sait pas
où le PS habite sur cette question
41 43 ans 43 à nuités
60 ans 40 annuités a été signé dans les
conditions que vous savez sur un bout de
table au bout de la nuit il n'a pas été
validé par les militants du Parti
socialiste moi je m'excuse je n'ai pas
été consulté en tant que militant du PS
donc je considère que c'est un accord
d'opportunité parce que voilà
pistolet sur la tempe la tête au sol et
le genou sur le sur la gorge on a signé
cet accord
vous défendez le matin sur cette partie
là de l'accord parce qu'il y avait
d'autres parties que je soutiens
notamment la hausse significative du
SMIC mais cette partie là je me sens pas
concerné parce que c'est 80 milliards
d'euros on le sait pour y arriver et que
donc aujourd'hui ce n'est pas une
priorité dans le cadre des des grands
déséquilibres financiers de l'État donc
par contre le maintien à 62 ans avec la
réforme Touraine c'est une réforme qui
permet d'assurer le financement de la
retraite par répartition sans aboutir
finalement à faire payer au plus grand
nombre parce que c'est six Français sur
10 selon les calculs de de Madame borne
si Français sur 10 qui seront de fait
pénalisés sans aucun effort demandé à
d'autres
l'objectif c'est quoi Monsieur Lecuyer
c'est 13 milliards d'euros 13 milliards
d'euros aujourd'hui potentiellement des
déficits moyens par an c'est beaucoup
d'argent si vous le ramenez 3000
milliards d'euros de dettes publiques
dans notre pays et sans compter sur
l'État aux pots pour récompenser le
régime des retraites des fonctionnaires
tout à fait l'état et lui-même un
employeur donc c'est normal qu'il paye
les retraites de ces serviteurs qui ont
servi pendant de nombreuses années ce
que je dis c'est qu'il n'y a pas eu de
réflexion potentielle sur qui pourrait
contribuer quand nous nous proposons une
taxe sur les super profits qui
d'ailleurs mettra appliqué par un
gouvernement de droite en Angleterre
vis-à-vis de Shell et pour les
énergéticiens on essaie de trouver de
l'argent quand on propose éventuellement
de réfléchir sur les cotisations des
entreprises en la matière modestement
mais on essaie de trouver de l'argent
l'impôt sur le capital qui a été
supprimé par Monsieur Macron peut-être
peut être aussi un moyen d'équilibre
pour ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que 13 milliards d'euros excusez-moi
c'est pour chacun d'entre nous c'est une
somme incommensurable mais c'est le
trait de plume par rapport au budget de
l'État et par rapport aux déficit qui
existe je ne dis pas qu'il faut graver
difficile il dit simplement qu'il faut
être équilibré et si les Français sont
dans la rue demain c'est parce qu'ils
n'en peuvent plus une petite question
sur la stratégie à adopter dès lors il y
a le mouvement dans la rue mais il y a
évidemment un travail parlementaire
alors Boris Vallot du groupe PS à
l'Assemblée hier exactement
ne semblait pas exclure de déposer un
très grand nombre d'amendements à
l'instar de la France insoumise vous
soutenez cette stratégie ce n'est pas
notre tradition
mais si on en est si on doit en arriver
là parce que risque de 49-3 voire de 47
ans maintenant risque de bon de blocage
et de contrainte du temps de débat
ce serait une révolution dans la
pratique des parlementaires socialistes
mais si vous l'acceptez
mon groupe deuxième groupe du Sénat dire
mais on prendra tous les moyens pour
dire non à cette
moyennement le groupe en décidera mais
je sens monter y compris dans mon groupe
c'est la terre
une colère parce que la réforme est
considérée comme un populaire enfin le
pas considérer elle est impopulaire que
du chiffrement et les pour nous injuste
et inutile quand vous cumulez les trois
et bien oui il y a un ras-le-bol quels
sont les autres moyens de déposer un
très grand nombre d'amendements au Sénat
qu'est-ce que vous allez faire vous
savez il suffit effectivement que chaque
sénateur dépose x amendement et on peut
faire durer
un enjeu je n'excuse pas de faire parce
que malheureusement et bien il faudra
dire à la majorité de droite macroniste
et LR que le peuple français ne veut pas
de cette réforme
premier mot là-dessus hier lors de ses
vœux Gérard Larcher a dit il nous faudra
échapper aux postures et au blocage pour
répondre aux inquiétudes et aux
questions de nos concitoyens sur cette
réforme vous partagez ça
je dirais dans son
vendeur mais surtout son son souci du
consensus voilà il dit ce qu'il pense il
est sincère la matière simplement et
Gérard Larcher et que j'aime beaucoup et
quand même un sénateur de droite qui va
soutenir une réforme de droite dans le
blocage vous sentez pas visé parce que
Gabriel Attal il dit que vous les
socialistes la France insoumise les
comics vous êtes le camp du blocage oui
j'ai même compris que dans l'esprit
monsieur Macron nous étions le camp de
les responsabilités ça a été dit il y a
quelques heures manifestement bien
écoutez ils diront tout cela aux
Français qui demain seront dans la rue
on va passer un autre sujet Julien oui
alors petite question sur la justement
ce dossier de la hausse des prix le
gouvernement veut mettre en place un
panier anti-inflation en demandant au
distributeur de vendre un panier de
produits de première nécessité une
vingtaine à peu près de les vendre à
coutant est-ce que c'est une bonne
initiative selon vous oui oui enfin
encore une fois
les primes quel que soit leur
dénomination les mesures qui permettent
à quelqu'un de gagner quelques euros
mais le vrai problème chez les cuisses
demandons depuis longtemps une
conférence salariale
est-ce que quand vous remplissez votre
voiture moi j'ai une petite 208 c'est
pas une grosse voiture 208 j'ai fait mon
plein il y a trois ou quatre jours 82
jours vous imaginez moi pour moi c'est
supportable
mais pour un smicard à 1300 euros de
salaire net c'est énorme c'est énorme et
donc oui alors je dis bah oui on va
prendre on va prendre ce qu'on nous
donne mais le problème c'est que dans
une logique quasiment de charité de
charité bien ordonnée comme dirait
l'autre ça ne suffira pas à éteindre la
grogne c'est pour ça que non non les
vraiment ce sentiment d'injustice est
profond dans mon pays je suis peut-être
que je me trompe mais je vois beaucoup
de gens notamment cette période dans les
vœux etc des gens qui viennent me saluer
je suis je suis inquiet je vous le dis
vraiment sincèrement pour la situation
sociale et sur les conséquences de
colère qui qui en découlent l'autre
sujet d'actualité c'est Noël le grec
vous étiez une idée sport vous avez
connu Noël le grec est une enquête a été
contre lui pour harcèlement moral et
sexuel il démonte toutes les accusations
qui le visent est-ce qu'il doit
démissionner
en retrait
moi j'ai travaillé avec Noël le Greg
dans des conditions improbables comme
ils disent des sports c'est-à-dire
c'était pour l'organiser l'Euro 2016
pendant la période des attentats je peux
vous dire que
les 51 matchs de l'Euro 2016 je les ai
encore bien en tête
et après il hyper cachée après Charlie
après le Bataclan après le Stade de
France organisé quelques mois plus tard
l'Euro 2016 c'était une sacrée gageure
bon on a réussi à le faire sans ce qu'il
y ait le moindre incident le moindre
donc et le Great était un partenaire du
ministère et du ministre en l'occurrence
et donc moi j'ai ce souvenir d'une
co-construction avec d'un Arcas neuve
sous l'autorité de François Hollande que
je n'oublie pas à partir de là voilà
j'ai bien vu toutes les critiques toutes
les remarques
je pense que dans c'est en grande
difficulté aujourd'hui mais une enquête
judiciaire est lancée vous attendez
je dis pas qu'il doit démissionner si le
décide est bien voilà tout le monde
comprendra que c'est pour apaiser ce
monde du football qui est en attendant
les résultats de l'enquête c'est ce que
vous dites c'est sa responsabilité moi
j'ai pas j'ai pas d'ordre et
heureusement à lui donner ce que je sais
par contre c'est que la Fédération
française de football comme toutes les
autres fédérations Olympiques ont une
délégation de service public du
ministère et Madame oudia Castéra je
crois était très clair sur le sujet
de la Voix du Nord
exclusivité en effet Gabriel Attal le
ministre du Budget a évoqué le plan
d'aide au buralisme mais c'est pas
là-dessus que je voulais vous vous
interroger il a fait une déclaration
aussi sur le service national universel
puisqu'elle a été le secrétaire deadsta
qui l'a qui a lancé ce projet en 2019
il soutient la généralisation du service
national universel qui devrait être
annoncé prochainement voire même son
obligation pour pour les jeunes est-ce
que pour vous c'est hors sol comme
proposition alors si vous regardez les
chiffres aujourd'hui le SNU c'est
combien personne 30000
une génération c'est combien 800000 bon
voilà j'ai envie de dire la mécénite si
vous me permettez l'expression et
service national universel il n'est pas
national il n'est pas universel
aujourd'hui je suis pas sûr que ce soit
un grand service donc moi je défends le
service civique qui est beaucoup plus
intéressant pour les jeunes qui permet
une véritable insertion et pour qu'il
soit universel il faut qu'il soit
obligatoire vous avez raison ce qui veut
dire qu'il faut changer la constitution
et bien je pense qu'on a d'autres
priorités
qui va vous concerner demain soir
j'en doute pas permettra à l'issue du
vote des adhérents le nom du prochain
secrétaire premier secrétaire du Parti
socialiste alors vous soutenez vous-même
la candidature de Nicolas Meyer
Rossignol contre l'actuel Premier
secrétaire Olivier Faure qui a retenu
qui a réuni derrière son texte
d'orientation vendredi dernier près de
49 49,15 % des suffrages contre 30,5
pour le maire de Rouen ça c'est pour le
tableau est-ce que vous croyez encore
malgré ce score de Nicolas Mayer
Rossignol à une victoire demain soir de
votre candidat alors déjà globalement ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que la direction
nationale sortante pilotée par Olivier
Faure
facialement on peut dire que c'est un
bon score 49% et des brouettes mais
c'est la première fois depuis le congrès
de Metz 1979 et c'est un éléphant qui
qui s'en souvient
que la direction nationale n'est pas
majoritaire bon très peu mais elle est
pas majoritaire c'est comme ça et
surtout les deux autres textes par
rapport au texte de Monsieur Faure était
opposé à voilà cette fameuse ligne qui
pour nous en tout cas fait que nous
sommes plutôt dans une logique de
satellisation
au sein de la gauche de LFI alors que
nous voulons que le PS retrouve tout son
éclat au sein de la gauche parce qu'on
pense que nous sommes les seuls à
pouvoir amener la gauche 79 le vainqueur
de de cette élection c'était François
Mitterrand accompagné par le CRS auquel
j'appartenais d'ailleurs c'est pas
plutôt bon signe pour Olivier fort nous
verrons bien nous verrons bien ce que je
sais oui mais c'est Mitterrand qu'il
gagne le Congrès contre la direction
sortant donc
voilà donc vous croyez que le fait la
meilleure au Seigneur sera le futur
français interne
vous allez vite en pause je suis pas sûr
que Umi pense par contre ce que je sais
c'est que la la gauche s'est construite
avec avec le PS dans la Cinquième
République sur la base d'un rapport de
force moi je crois en rapport de force
en politique je pense que elle est fille
aussi croire un rapport de force qui est
bien normal et les filles étaient
aujourd'hui la force dominante en tout
cas facialement au sein de la gauche
elle veut être la force centrale moi je
pense que c'est pas la bonne solution
que nous soyons avec la France
est-ce qu'il faut c'est que nous soyons
dans une alliance qui ne nous mène pas à
être des alignés alliés mais pas aligné
pour ça il faut sortir de la nupesse ou
pas c'est quelque chose qu'on a vraiment
du mal à comprendre vis-à-vis de Nicolas
Mayer aussi
j'entendais pour le français moyen c'est
un peu complexe parce qu'on est dans la
stratégie qui touche parfois la tactique
ce que nous disons c'est que Olivier
Faure porte une ligne qui consiste à
dire l'union fait la force le PS est
aujourd'hui faible disons-le qu'il est
très clairement et c'est au travers de
l'Union que nous retrouverons des
couleurs nous ne pensons l'inverse nous
pensons en réaffirmant la place centrale
du PS que nous pouvons négocier une
union qui soit équilibrée
il est critique vis-à-vis de la nuque
hier il s'est affiché il était au
meeting unitaire de la nuque avec la
France insoumise
pas du tout je vous ai dit allier mais
pas aligné ça veut dire ne pas être
soumis dépendant concrètement quand nous
ensemble avec les filles nous nous
battons pour lutter contre la
privatisation la DP on a réussi quand
nous battons aujourd'hui contre les
retraites enfin contre la réforme des
retraites nous nous sommes ensemble et
comme quand nous défendons une taxation
des super profits nous sommes ensemble
donc nous sommes capables de travailler
ensemble simplement c'est qui doit être
celui qui fixe le cap mais justement
on peut leur faire dire ce qu'on veut
évidemment mais là les projections
pourraient mener par exemple à une
victoire de d'Olivier Faure ils sont
premiers secrétaire il pourrait avoir le
Conseil national mais pas le bureau
national enfin est-ce que concrètement
une victoire de Livier Faure mène à un
PS qui sera un gouvernable le PS
aujourd'hui est partagé je dis pas
diviser ni fracturé partager c'est clair
et il y a deux lignes stratégiques en
termes d'alliance
une portée par Olivier fort et l'autre
portée par les deux autres sensibilités
je salue Hélène Geoffroy qui nous a
d'ailleurs rejoint sans condition pour
voter Nicolas
reviendra pas de vous compter vous
comptez chauffer est-ce qu'Olivier
du premier tour entre guillemets même si
c'est pas vraiment un second tour nous
allons demain
c'est qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes 23000
24000 militants que moi j'ai connu un PS
votant et votant votant et peut-être un
petit peu plus de militants d'adhérents
en tout cas et que j'ai connu un PS à
120000 130
000 cartes et je me dis donc mon parti a
besoin de retrouver une force une ligne
idéologique et
Olivier fort a fait beaucoup
l'inventaire n'a qu'un cadenas précédent
et bien il faudra aussi que cet
inventaire soit fait
d'une certaine manière l'inventaire
quand quand le premier secretaire les
roses sur le retour des des éléphants on
évoquant les comptes de nature adverse
évidemment les soutiens qui les
accompagnent ça vous agace de à chaque
fois d'être moi j'ai des vieux principes
parce que je suis un éléphant je pense
qu'il ne faut jamais mordre la main qui
vous a nourri
de François Hollande premier secrétaire
il a été grâce à François Hollande
secrétaire général du groupe à
l'Assemblée il a une circonscription
bon voilà ne jamais mordre la main qui
vous a nourrit voilà mais c'est un vieux
principe je sais bien que aujourd'hui
tout ceci est parfois dépassé Monsieur
Olivier Faure et élu où est-ce qu'il
faut reconstruire en dehors du PS
en 75 j'ai combattu Jean-Luc Mélenchon
quand il était au PS j'ai pas envie que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon gagne par procuration
un congrès aujourd'hui parce qu'il a
jamais gagné de congrès au PS et le
candidat par procréation de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon en tout cas quand je vois les
déclarations des leaders de LFI
vis-à-vis de lier fort manifestement ils
ont choisi ils ont choisi
d'un signe donc le rapport de force
jamais le rapport de soumission je
merci Patrick canaire la Une de La Voix
du Nord Julien exclusivité l'interview
de Gabriel Attal qui donne quelques
enfin qui en tout cas va aider les
buralistes à survivre à la baisse des
ventes de tabac et trafic illicite et
donc ce matin dans la voie d'une merci
Julien merci beaucoup